aujourd'hui échange standard vous emmène
à nevers a smile poissonnière soit ni
créer répare des vélos pour une courte
expérience elles vont échanger leurs
activités alors c'est parti pour les
changes suivez nous ben voilà donc
bonjour soigner bienvenus pourtant stage
donc quand tu vois c'est une passionnée
donc ça change complètement de ce que tu
fais donc on va préparer une lotte comme
ça justement être un petit peu comment
je fais on prépare déjà de poissons que
ce soit les bars les dorades maison
corner
les macros pour tout ce qui est vraiment
difficile à préparer à la maison je vais
essayer bien là il faut que tu coupes
toute la peau qui déborde là je pense
pas comme ça voilà des droitiers ok tu
coupes comme ça elle puis tu peux plus
cela presque chirurgicale des trucs à
faire dans l'orne
c'est marrant tout ça déborde
comme cet homme vêtu comme ça voilà donc
après la chute enregistrée de l'eau
couteau pour parfait si on me demandait
de découpe et je pense qu'à la fin il
resterait pas grand chose donc voilà il
ya des partis qui imagine comment la
charcuterie ou à la boucherie les
parties nobles et puis il ya aussi et je
vois bien l'esthétique qui est
importante faut que le poisson il soit
qui ait rien qui dépasse
voilà c'est non il ya un savoir faire
c'est sûr et après on enlève carrément
la peau qui y par dessus non lorsque ce
qui est vraiment gros que ça fasse
vraiment jolie propres
après on va juste l'arrangé un petit peu
là tu peux la mettre avec l'autre
combien vous voulez de carnet je
l'espère le carrelet c'est ça tu prouves
ça oui tu les mets dedans
ouais c'est pour le poids il faut à peu
près 600 g 586 ans maxime tu mets sur la
balance les 530 c'est parfait porte moi
perso et 1,3 pour le lou la partie
relationnel avec le client si je la
connais à peu près ce que c'est ça à peu
près la même chose mais j'ai bien vu
qu'il ya des gens avaient leurs
habitudes et à celle d'à peu près ce
qu'ils veulent je trouve ça super et
voilà je tenterais passer une bonne
journée
à bientôt merci au revoir bon ça y est
tout s'est bien passé soignée et une
bonne apprentis très très bien j'aurais
bien gardé mais elle a sans métier donc
on va aller voir ce qui se passe de
l'autre côté
eh ben c'est parti on va échanger les
expériences et c'est parti
[Musique]
et ben voilà ce marronnier c'est dans la
partie magasin plutôt atelier où je me
sois les vélos des clients et on va
faire un changement de pneus sur ce joli
vélo voilà les faits le boulou
on va dégonfler pneus on est bon
donc ok là on est dégonflé donc va
prendre un démonte-pneu on prendra juste
montrer début où tu vas chercher le du
rythme là oui tu va l'ouvrir et après tu
fais toulouse et l'attenté dedans tu
peux presque faire glisser tu peux tout
irait donc tu fais tu enlève tout voilà
et donc là on a enlevé peu de on va
prendre le peu de tout neuf et on va
l'installer sur la roue en faisant bien
attention de le mettre dans le bon sens
donc la roue tu la mets dans ce sens là
le sens de roulement et dans ce sens là
tu avances et donc sur ton pneus tu as
un sens de crampons kit indique le sens
de roulement l'accord donc on met
d'abord un seul côté
voilà et ensuite tu va installer la
chambre r quand je vais le passer
donc tu commences par la bac dans le bon
sens intérieur tutoriel
voilà
[Musique]
donc là on a plus qu'à bouffer
n'hésite pas été jambes d'utiliser des
gens sinon si tu utilises tu que tes
bras tu vas tu te fatigues
voilà on met la vitesse et en août et
après on revit à la clé 15
ouais dans ce sens la série de ce côté
ouais tu pousses voilà et de l'autre
côté du sens inverse
super et ensuite ou du pas de remettre
le frein et voilà il a changé le pin up
les jamais changé de pneus dans ma vie
donc c'était l'occasion mais je te
remercie soigner puis je vais m'acheter
un vélo et je saurai change un peu on
explose a pu être fait 2 a fait carrière
maintenant tania va nous rejoindre pour
la traditionnelle photo de fin
[Musique]